[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد في خطوه تمثل استكمال
عوده سوريا الى المنظومات العربيه اكدت
رئاسه السوريه ان مشاركه رئيس بشار الاسد
في اعمال الدوره الثانيه وثلاثين للقمه
العربيه بجده جاءت بعد سلسله من الخطوات
التي اتخذتها دول العربيه اتجاه سوريا
بغيه انهاء عزلتها ولكن لماذا غبت سوريا
لاكثر من عقد المشكله تعود لنوفمبر من عام
2011 عندما قرر وزراء الخارجيه العرب في
اجتماع طارق
عضويه سوريا في الجامعه لحين التزام
الحكومه السوريه بتنفيذ بنود المبادره
العربيه وكان اخر حضور رسمي لبشار الاسد
في قمه عربيه عام 2010 والتي اقيمت في
مدينه سرت الليبيه اما عن كيفيه العوده في
الجامعه العربيه اتخذت قراره اعاده سوريا
الى مقعدها عقب حراك عربي قادته السعوديه
ومصر والاردن لحل الازمه السوريه ووفق
مبدا الخط وه مقابل الخطوه وبما لا يتعارض
مع قرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54 القاده
العرب اعتبروا ان قمه جده ستكون فرصه
للتشاور والتسويه بعد ازمات عميقه استمرت
خلالها معاناه السوريين عاما تلو العامه
[موسيقى]
على مدى تاريخها الذي يقترب من حاجز
الثمانين عاما كانت لجامعه الدول العربيه
ادوار مفصليه من ابرزها الاسلام في حصول
دول عربيه على استقلالها مثل ما حدث في
دول منها الجزائر وسلطنه عمان اضافه الى
دور محوري في تسويه النزاعات العربيه
حيث تحظى بدرجه قبول عاليه من الاطراف
المتنازعه لدورها تشجيع التعاون العربي
العربي عبر المنظمات المتخصصه التي تشكلت
داخل اطار الجامعه وخارجها
وتمثيل الدول العربيه في المحافل
والمنظمات الدوليه مثل الامم المتحده
ومنظماتها
واعود من جديد الى ضيوفي هنا في الاستوديو
فهد شقران صحفي السعودي ومستشار مركز
المسبار للدراسات كذلك من القاهره الدكتور
محمد مجاهد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري
للفكر والدراسات الاستراتيجيه من لندن
فايز ساره الكاتب والسياسي سوري ومن دمشق
عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتبه الصحفي احييكم
من جديد ضيوف الكرام استاذ فايز
الحرف في سوريا خلفت واحده من اسوا
الازمات الانسانيه وهجرت الملايين في
الواقع عوده سوريا
واسترجاع مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه الى
اي مدى قادر ان يساعد في حلحله الوضع من
حيث عوده اللاجئين ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه
هذا التطور في خصوص هذا الملف
انا بعتقد انه هذا هو الشيء الاساسي
بموضوع عوده السوري او عدم عودتها للعرب
لانه بالاصل العرب
الغوا او او منعوا سوريا من الحضور في
الجامعه العربيه بفعل موقفها كما قال
تقريركم بفعل موقفها من المبادره العربيه
رفض المبادره العربيه هيك بدات القصه
واستمرت هيك 12 سنه من المعاناه من من قتل
وتشريد وخلافه ادت الى ما هو عليه الحال
الان وهو الداعي الان لدى القمه العربيه
لاعاده سوريا ليست ليست قصه ليست قصه
الزلزال هي السبب ولا قصه الكبتاجون هي
السبب ولا الارهاب هو السبب لان هذه
الاسباب الثلاثه لدينا في المحيط الاقليمي
ما هو اشد خطرا مما هو القائل يعني مثلا
سيطره حزب الله الميليشيا الارهابيه
الشيعيه اللي موجوده بلبنان على لبنان
وامتداداتها في الاقليم بما في ذلك سوريا
هو اخطر من كل الجماعات نشاط الجماعات
الارهابيه في المنطقه ايضا قصه الكبتاجون
اليوم ما في الف قصه كيبتاجون جاريه يعني
اللاجئين اللي نشروا بالعالم العربي اللي
بتعاني منهم مصر ولبنان والاردن والعراق
وتركيا والسعوديه حتى وبلدان الخليج اي اي
كمان انا بعتقد شيء انساني يفوق قضايا
المعتقلين قضايا المعتقلين اللي مئات
الالاف ما في ما في كشف عن مصائرهم
كمان هاي قضيه انسانيه
نقاط موضوع المعتقلين من النقاط الموضوعه
تفضل باختصار انت كرمت
المعتقلين واللاجئين هي نقاط غير تفاوضيه
اصلا اي لا يجوز لاحد ان يفاوض فيها لا
احد يستطيع لا احد النظام ولا غيره
الموضوع كيف سيساهم عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه في هكذا الموضوع خلينا
نسمع راي الاستاذ عبد الحميد
تفضل تفضل لازم لازم احكي عن عن حدا قاعد
عم يسامح بحقوق ضحايا واقول ان الضحايا هن
الوحيدين اللي يسامحوا وانا من منطقه من
الضحايا هم اللي بيسامحوا بقول انه من
حقنا كسوريين نشوف حل لقضيتنا اكثر من اي
واحد ثاني لكن
على اساس
اعاده الحقوق لاصحابها ان يطلق سراح
المعتقلين اولا ان يعود اللاجئين الى
بيوتهم ان يجري ان يجري ان تجري عمليه
اعاده بناء او تسويه سياسيه كما نصل قرار
22 14
ولانه الموضوع فيه نقاط معقده للغايه
نحاول تفكيك هذا الملف لفهم مختلف النقاط
اولويات الدول ساعود لك السيد فايز ساعود
لك فقط اسمح لي ان نشرك كذلك معنا بقيه
ضيوف استاذ عبد الحميد في خصوص عوده
اللاجئين هل يمكن ان يمثل عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه منطلقا لحلول حقيقيه هذه
المره
يفترض ان يكون ذلك فيما يتعلق بالمساله
اللاجئين انا افترض ان يكون العوده
العلاقه السوريه مع العالم العربي وانا
اقول بصراحه اتمنى ان تبقى لا تعمم نقول
العرب انا اقول بان الرباعيه العربيه
تمكنت من انجاز شيء وبالتالي العمل العربي
الذي يسمى العمل العربي المشترك على مد
العقود الماضيه لم ينتج حلا سياسيا لاي
مشكله داخل البيت العربي وبالتالي انا
اعتقد بان تجزيع هذه القضيه وانتاج
صبغه جديده صيغه جديده للعمل العربي
الفعال والفاعل من خلال تشخيص المرض
واعطاء العلاج فيما يتعلق بالرباط العربيه
يمكن ان يؤتي ثمارا اعود الى مساله
اللاجئين
وما تحديدا مع الرباعيه العربيه خارطتها
يجب ان يكون منطلقا تاسيسيا لهذه العوده
الطوعيه والامنه والتي تصون حقوق الجميع
ولكن بالمقابل لا استطيع ان اقول بان هذه
العوده وانتهى الامر ان نضعها عنوان على
على اي اجنده اي عمل هذه العوده لا يمكن
ان تكون بقرار ولا يمكن ان تكون
بتبوس الشوارب ولا يمكن ان تكون ايضا
بعواطف بدون عمل حقيقي يؤسس لان تقنع
هؤلاء اللاجئين ان عودتهم ستكون ولكن
هنا تحتيه ويجب ان يؤسس لهم ايضا حضرتك
تحدثت عن اكثر من نقطه تحدثت عن تامين
عودتهم وهذا من سيتكلف به
نعم انا هذا هو الذي اريد ان اصل اليه ان
العمل العربي مع الرباعي العربيه مع
الجانب السوري مع الدوله السوريه مع
الحكومه السوريه يجب ان يكون هناك بلوره
لمواقف تقوم على ثلاثه اسس الاول هو ان
يكون هناك استعداد داخلي في سوريا بمعاونه
هذه الرباعيه العربيه والعرب عموما لتسهيل
عودتهم بقرار سياسي
ووطني الامر العامل الاساس الاخر هو ان
يكون هناك تحرك من هذه الحاضره العربيه مع
دمشق باتجاه الحكومات التي تروي هؤلاء
اللاجئين بيروت عمان وانقره لان العمليه
لا تقف عند الدمش ولا ولا عند عمان ولا
عند الكل هذه مشكله عامه والاساس الثالث
هو ان تكون هذه العوده قد تم التاسيس لها
على بنطاقين نطاق سياسي وطني بحيث يتاكد
ويشعر هذا اللاجئ بان عودته ستكون فعلا
امنه وتنتهي كل التبعات عليها والامر
الاهم هو تكون هناك بنيه تحتيه وان يكون
هناك اعاده بناء على الاقل بدون
ترى حضرتك بانه اعاده الاعمار يجب ان تسبق
مثلا مثل هكذا او اعاده بنيه تحت بالتوازي
باختصار جديد هذه المساله تدرس بالتوازي
يعني الخطوه الاولى تاتي منها باتجاه
اللاجئين عقده العقده الامنيه والسياسيه
ومن هنا قلنا في هذه المنطقه علينا ان
نبدا لكي نطمئن اللاجئ بان بنيته تحتيه
ستكون مرافقه
حتى تنتهي اعاده الاعمار سيعود اللاجئون
هذا دكتور دكتور مجاهد الزيات ما المقاربه
التي يمكن ان تقدمها الجامعه العربيه
لتسهيل هذا الملف عوده اللاجئين واعاده
الاعمار الاستاذ عبد الحميد يقول بانه هذه
ملفات يجب ان تبنى بطريقه متوازيه ما رايك
يعني هو في البدايه
لابد ان يكون هناك قبول من الرئيس السوري
والحكومه السوريه بان الرباعيه كما قال
الاستاذ عبد الحميد وانا اتفق معه وانت
تنفرد الرباعيه وليس عملا جماعيا مشتركا
كبيرا الرباعيه ان يكون هناك قبول بانما
تقوم به الرباعيه ليس تدخلا في الشؤون
الداخليه السوريه هذه النقطه الاولى اذا
تم الاقرار بذلك فان يطرح على مائده
الحديث ما بين الطرفين الرباعيه والحكومه
السوريه القضايا الشائكه التي جرى الحوار
بخصوصها قبل العوده قبل قرار العوده وعلى
اولوياتها الدافع العامل الانساني المتعلق
اولا الافراج عن المعتقلين كبادره وحسن
نيه والنقطه الثانيه عوده اللاجئين دون
مسائله امنيه وعندما نتحدث عن عوده
اللاجئين هنصبح مضطرين الى اين يعود
اللاجئين السوريين من الخارج فهي الى
مناطقهم المناطق المدمره لابد ان يكون
هناك حديثا واضحا وقبولا دوليا بان يتم
اعمار المناطق المدمره للاجئين العائدين
الى تلك المناطق والحديث هنا على المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه السوريه ولكن
هناك قضيه اخرى بانك لاجئين من منطقه
الشمال التي يسيطر عليها تركيا والفصائل
العسكريه وخصوصا جبهه النصره التي تقيم
حكومه هناك هل هذه النقطه ستكون مطروحه
ومن المسؤول عنها في تلك المنطقه وهناك
اللاجئين في لدى الاقراض منطقه الحكم
الذاتي الكردي هذه قضايا ليس يتم الحديث
فيها فقط مع الحكومه السوريه ولكن سيتم
الحديث معها ايضا مع تلك الاطراف المعنيه
والمنخرطه فيها سيد فهد لما نتحدث عن
اعاده اعمار ونتحدث عن عوده اللاجئين
وتامينهم وضيوف اتفقوا كما سمعت لهم حضرتك
بانه يجب على هذه الملفات ان يعمل عليها
بطريقه متوازيه طيب ما هو سيقول البعض
بانه اعاده او اعاده
الاعمار يجب ان تتم بعد الانتهاء من تامين
المنطقه المنطقه داخل السوري فيه مجموعات
مسلحه ومجموعات مسلحه تعتمر ليس باوامر
الدوله السوريه ولكن لكل مجموعه لديها من
تاتمر به كيف سيتم حل هكذا الموضوع معقد
على هذا السؤال بنقطتين ثنتين النقطه
الاولى ان هذه ان الدول العربيه لا تستطيع
ان تخوض معارك الاخرين وانما تقدم مبادرات
وتاسس لجلس لطاولات حوار سواء كان هذا في
الملف السوري او بالملف اللبناني او
بالملف الليبي او في اي ملف كامل ملفات
المنطقه المعقده ثانيا الدول ذات سياده من
حق اي دوله ان تطبع مع من كان مع اي دوله
كانت اذا كان ذلك يحقق لها مصالحها ويدرى
عنها اعباء وكلفات معينه
انا دائما يقول في مشكله المشكله لدى
العرب انهم يريدون من دون الخليج ان تتحول
الى جمعيات خيريه وان كل معركه يبداها حزب
الله او يبداها تبداها حماس في غزه او
يبداها ايا كان في اي مكان كان ان على دول
الخليج ان تقوم بدعمها ماديا ومعنويا
وامنيا الخليج لديها مصالح في السابق كان
هناك نعم هي تستطيع الان ان تقدم امرين
اثنين مثل ما حصل في لبنان
تقدم الدعم لحل سياسي داخلي ولحل ممكن ان
يتفق عليها اللبنانيين او السوريين ثانيا
تقدم اغاثات انسانيه لكن ان تقوم بالدخول
في تخوم حرب محدده يخوضها اناس ضد فريق ضد
فريق هذا المستحيل وممكن يعني
اذا انت
السعوديه دعمت كثيرا الحل السياسي ودعمت
مؤتمرات كثيره في الشرق والغرب ولكن هناك
مشكله اساسيه
بين الطرفين يجب ان يجب ان نفرق بين علاقه
المعارضه السوريه او ان يكن تسميتها
بالنظام السوري وبين علاقه الدول العربيه
بالنظام السوري
هنا فرض اساسي يجب ان يفهموا بعض احببتنا
السوريين اول الفلسطينيين او حتى
اللبنانيين لنبقى في الملف السوري حضرتك
تحدثت وقلت بان دول الخليج ليست الدول
التي تدخل حروب
ترمي بنفسها في حروب على فكره انا لما
طرحت سؤال لم اكن
في بالي ان اتحدث عن خوف حروب عسكريه انا
المحت الى
ان اقول لك مش حتى هذا انا كنت اشير الى
موضوع التقارب السعودي الايراني وموضوع
التقارب التركي مع مختلف الدول العربيه
هذا ما كنت اشير له بمعنى انه هل هذا
التقارب الايراني السعودي وايران حاضره في
داخل السوري هل عوده تركيا ومحاوله اعاده
علاقاتها مع الدول العربيه مصر بالاساس
يمكن لهذه التطورات الدبلوماسيه الج مقدمه
ان تؤثر على موضوع اعاده لاجئين الانتهاء
من المجموعات المسلحه هذا ما اشرت له نعم
هناك رمال سياسيه متحركه الحوار مع ايران
من الاساس كان مطروح من الاساس كان مطروح
وطرحه الامير محمد بن سلمان في عده حوارات
وهي دوله جاره لابد ان لابد ان تسير خطوه
وهي تسير خطوه وانت تتفق على نقاط معينه
ممكن ان تخفف من ازمات المنطقه نعم لن يكن
هناك اتفاق بنسبه مئه بالمئه مع اي دوله
سواء سوريا او ايران يعني من المستحيل ان
يكون هناك اتفاق مطلق لكن ان يكون هناك
توازن ان تخفف الاعباء على المجتمعات هذه
المجتمعات التي تعاني من ازمات اقتصاديه
سواء المجتمع الايراني او المجتمع السوري
او اللبناني الذي يعيش كارثه ايضا لا ننسى
ان مزاج المنطقه المزاج السياسي في
المنطقه صار اكثر تحررا من القيود الغربيه
ومن الاملاءات الغربيه وهذا ذكره ايضا
الامير محمد بن سلمان بوضوح في مقابلته في
اطلانتك
ما كان سابقا من اداء سياسي في دول الخليج
انتهى الان نحن امام جيل سياسي مختلف سواء
في الامارات العربيه المتحده او في
السعوديه او في اكثر من دوله لذلك الحوار
مع ايران اساسي ليس
لتصفير مشكلاتنا مع ايران هناك
حوار رحله طويله من اجل ان تصل الى هدف
معين وهدف محدد من بينها ابرزها ايقاف او
اطفاء ما تيسر من الحرائق المشتعله في
المنطقه وضحت الفكره خلينا نسمع ضيوفها
الكرام ومشاهدينا كذلك الى ما قال في هذا
الاطار في ملف اعاده اللاجئين معاون وزير
الخارجيه السوري نستمع ونعود هنا يظهر
الترابط بشكل كبير بين موضوع اعاده
الاعمار وعوده اللاجئين لانه كما ذكرت من
يريد ان يعود الى سوريا يريد ان يعود الى
مكان تتوفر فيه ابسط الخدمات
طيب
هذا عون وزير الخارجيه لقناه العربيه فيما
يخص هذا الاطار ولكن يبقى سؤال هو في
الواقع الوقت يدركنا وبقيت مجموعه كبيره
من الاسئله نحاول ان نختم دقيقه لكل ضيف
لو سمحت لاستاذ فايز هل تعتقد بان هذه
الملفات ستكون اولويه وسيرجا الحديث عن
الحل السياسي الوقت ادركنا استاذ فايز
يعني
انا من اسمي لازم اخذ لازم اخذ وقت اكثر
اسمي فايز ان شاء الله دايما
يعني انا بعتقد انه انه يعني لساتنا بعقل
اللي بيدفش المسؤوليات الى الاخرين
اذا كان النظام بالفعل جاد في حل او
التفاعل الايجابي مع المبادره العربيه ومع
القمه العربيه لازم يبطل دفش المسؤوليات
على المسؤوليات على الاخرين العقوبات اللي
صارت هي نتيجه السياسات اللي حصلت واليوم
موقف الناس
والهجره والمعتقلين هن بفعل السياسات اللي
تمت لازم النظام يغير هاي الموجه يفوت
ويعترف بمسؤولياته ويلاقي حلول ومعالجات
طالما العرب عم يمدوا ايده الخلاط طيب
استاذ عبد الحميد هل يمكن الحديث في الوقت
الحالي عن مسار سياسي جديد عن تعديل
دستوري عن انتخابات او ان الوضع بطرح
ملفات اكثر تعقيد اعاده الاعمار المجموعات
المسلحه اعاده اللاجئين هنا الاولويه وكل
ما هو سياسي مؤجل
الاولويات التي وضعت وفق خارطه الطريق
العربيه هي الجانب الامني الجانبي
الانساني والجانب السياسي لكن بالنظر الى
التحرك الدبلوماسي العربي ممثلا بمصر
وعمان وزيره الخارجيه المصري والاردني
وكذلك وزير الخارجيه السعودي حينما
تواصلوا مع بعض منظمات الامم المتحده ومع
بدرسون
عن موضوع اللجنه الدستوريه والتفاوض في
هذا الاطار اعتقد انها اشاره الى ان هذه
الملفات قد تاخذ مسارات متوازيه متزامنه
مع بعضها البعض وصولا الى
رزمه من الحلول الاوليه لمثال المساله
اعتقد
بان العمليه السياسيه ومتطلباتها ستكون
عامله طمانينه لكل الاطراف الداخليه
السوريه المعارضه وغير المعارضه وهذا يعني
بان هذه الملفات اتوقع ان يكون لها مسارات
متوازيه ولكن ربما يتقدم الانسان على
الفكره الوقت انتهى تماما الخاص بهذه
الحلقه ولكن العربيه
تخصص تغطيه خاصه لقمه جده وكذلك لكل هذه
الملفات التي تحدثنا بها اود شكر ضيوفي
الكرام في الاستوديو صحفي السعودي ومستشار
مركز المسبار للدراسات شكرا لك وكذلك شكر
لضيوفه من القاهره الدكتور محمد مجاهد
الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر ودراسه
الاستراتيجيه من لندن في ساره الكاتب
والسياسي السوري ومن دمشق عبد الحميد
توفيق الكاتب الصحفي شكرا جزيلا لكم وعلى
متابعتكم طبعا العربيه ستخصص تغطيه لقمه
جده ولعوده مقعد سوريا لجامعه ادوار
العربيه ابقوا دائما في متابعتنا السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]
اتمنى ان تكون استعاده سوريا لمقعدها
مقدمه لانهاء ازمتها مع استئناف الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه الشقيقه شغله مقعدها
بمنظمتنا نحن ممتنون ان كل الدول العربيه
الان موجوده في هذه القمه
[موسيقى]
انتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم السعوديه بدلت جهد هائل من اجل
تحسين الاجواء العربيه ومن اجل
احتضان جميع الدول العربيه عوده سوريا
عوده في سياق
ساعه عربي لتسهيل تسويه الوضع السوري
سوريا لا يمكن ان تغيب عن اي قناه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات